I feel like with a story like this you
could either laugh or cry oh God this is
from The Daily Mail this is playing with
fire it could spark a lab generated
pandemic how about that experts slam
Boston lab where scientists have created
a new deadly coveted string with an 80
kill rate why why are they making this
so here's what they did actually simple
so the Omicron strain mutated over a
long period of time covid goes out kovid
kills a lot of people the alpha strain
was very deadly over time it was getting
more infectious but weaker that's how
viruses tend to go the Omicron strain
was very infectious but not as deadly
that makes sense if something's too
deadly people die before they can spread
the disease so these researchers took
the spike protein from Omicron and put
it on the alpha strain which is more
deadly creating an extremely infectious
and deadly virus which killed 8 in 10 of
the rodents infected why wow why did
they make this a little Christmas
present yeah why why was you know Peter
dazek of uh Echo Hut's Alliance doing
similar projects back before four of
course the larger coveted pandemic that
happened when he was exactly looking at
bats and coronaviruses in the Wuhan
level 3 Institute of virology uh that of
course had poor security protocols
according to many even State Department
protocols and documents that came out
there why did they do this and the
question is they're doing this on even
bigger levels than we could even imagine
and the argument here the basic argument
that they're making is we need to do
this in order so we find a solution for
it in the future number one a lot of
scientists argue that the probability of
something like this happening naturally
is virtually almost impossible but but
two why are you trying to make this
current strain that much worse when you
couldn't even figure out the original
strain there is no solution there is no
medical solution towards the original
strain so why are you studying why you
are are you wasting so much time looking
at some hypothetical when you can't even
figure out the original problem so so
that's something that needs to be
understood here as well as the fact that
again
Peter dazek is continuing to do the same
experiments in other countries we know
about this because it's it's Boston
University but what about the studies in
Laos what about the studies in Myanmar
what about the studies going on right
now in Vietnam that we don't know
anything about that Echo Health Alliance
by the way was was was subpoenaed was
told by the US government hey you got to
send us your notes about what you guys
were doing with the coronavirus in Wuhan
Eco Health Alliance even though they're
financed by the US government by Dr
fauci said no we're just not going to
give you any of the notes they're not
being transparent and they're being
rewarded with more grants that were just
issued a couple weeks ago continuing to
make viruses as lethal as they can why
are they doing this a lot of people
speculate bio weapons and then this
could be one reason why Bill Gates came
out a few months ago and said the second
pandemic is going to be a lot deadlier
he said that very promisingly and who in
the world happily probably what's that
saying we spend so much time wondering
if we could do it we never asked
ourselves if we should do it something
like that yeah I I'm like reading this
story where they're talking about
taking this protein and making you know
the so so the Omicron strain infected
mice the mice did not die they then
created like the Omicron s strain or
whatever they're calling it and it
killed eight out of ten and they were
like oh look we did it we made something
that can kill mice it's like you know I
look at that and I'm like yeah you could
have injected him with bleach that would
have killed him too right like obviously
this like you make a deadly virus it
will kill them I just I don't trust them
we had a conversation with Drew Miller
who has a PHD in you know nuclear
wartime battle field stuff or whatever
and he was saying
he was talking about how we have no bio
labs in the united like the United
States does not operate bioweapons labs
and I'm like it's just semantics if U.S
Laboratories are making extremely deadly
viruses that they're extremely
infectious and extremely lethal and you
argue they're not weapons because we
don't use them for that and I'm like so
so okay so so the question is if I have
a factory that make explosives
but we we use it for mining operations
right we're not making weapons then
someone comes in buys buys the company
and then sells them for war did we make
weapons or not
right so Like a Knife Company we we make
you know uh fancy knives for culinary
purposes and then someone buys them and
goes and fights with them did the
company manufacture weapons the answer
is yes they manufacture weapons was it
their intent no but it doesn't matter so
we're seeing this and I'm like hey that
is a bioweapon Now call it whatever you
want say what you want whatever you want
about it if you make a nuclear bomb and
say we just want to see if it would
explode but yeah okay well you're making
nuclear weapons yeah what's there's no
it's you know what man and I can even
make the argument knives culinary knives
have a purpose you you can cut your
steak you know how what are you going to
do you got you want to eat dinner you
gotta this virus has no purpose it's
literal the only purpose is killing
people so yeah anyway well these
researchers who I would assume know the
coronavirus better than anyone on earth
have looked at it more than anyone
obviously have they said anything in the
report about yes this was definitely
man-made in the lab or they've forbidden
from saying that do they know a lot
about this virus since again the
official story is we don't even know
exactly where it came from yeah we don't
have an origin we don't have a patient
zero we don't have any of that well
someone knows someone of course knows
but there's been a large cover-up effort
Echo Health Alliance doesn't want to
share their notes about what they were
even doing what U.S grant money from Dr
pouchy in 2020 right I thought it was uh
someone ate bat soup a block away from
the Wuhan right yeah
first and that's how it came yeah
there's also a peglin involved here I
think that was an episode of South Park
as well yeah uh but again no official
stories too yeah and ever since ever
since covered there has been there have
been 40 new biological Labs that have
been started up doing extremely
dangerous testing make mixing in viruses
and again there's no perfect security at
these places like we have to understand
it takes one small mistake it takes one
whole one puncture one is mistake one
intern
and that virus spreads everywhere so
where is the all these worthless
International organizations we have
where is the International effort and
treaty against
perflations
we have it all with nuclear weapons
where is this going on bio weapons are
apparently banned under treaties and
that's what we were talking about last
week and so it's like we're not making
weapons we're just making extremely
deadly viruses that serve no purpose
other than killing yeah right yeah so so
yeah we look at those treaties again and
exactly say what kind of research is
permitted what isn't well what if this
is a question that was brought up what
if all these other countries are doing
it and the US isn't
yeah exactly so you know with mutually
assured destruction I suppose the
argument is you know if we didn't have
nuclear weapons we'd be at the best
store or you know if anyone else then
they can call if anyone else who has
nukes who can threaten us so everybody
gets them and then you can't bully
someone
you could say something similar for uh
any kind of bioweapon it's like hey we
all have them so you better not release
them if the US wasn't doing it would
that be a risk I think the problem with
bio weapons is they're completely
undetectable with a nuclear weapon we
can see who did it yeah okay that came
from Russia and it's a Russian missile
somebody gets sick we have no idea what
it is or where it came from and then
it's going to spread everywhere and
affect everybody and yeah and this is
what's public imagine what's not public
imagine what secret imagine what else
they're doing that we don't know about
that's not in the United States that's
in Myanmar or in Ukraine or wherever it
may be that these people are taking
their money investing it and doing
research in extremely poor countries
where there's no transparency there's no
accountability and they prey on poorer
countries because they're able to get
away with more disastrous nasty stuff
that they wouldn't be able to get away
with here in the United States 2020
could have been the warm-up honestly
yeah I mean that's what Bill Gates says
Bill Gates says this is this is only one
of many pandemics to come you know he's
excited yeah he said he said the second
pandemic is going to be a lot deadlier
than this one is and I'll clarify too I
mean this is in mice so how that
directly translates may be very very
different they like it may be much much
higher in my centers in humans but
they're basically making the point that
the Omicron they tested didn't kill any
of the mice they made it more deadly it
killed 80 of them eight out of ten
so we'll see I got a prediction
I think
we talked about listen again we we
broached the subject on how a bio weapon
would be released and I said I think
that any nation that releases a bio
weapon will release a mild strain of it
on their own country first
here's what happens they create two
viruses hypothetically any country
the deadly variant and the mild variant
but they're very very similar they share
a lot of the same attributes they
release on their own population the flu
everybody gets it
point one percent mortality or point
zero one or whatever it is for the flu
then they release the massive maximum 60
deadly strain
on somewhere else in the world and when
that strain comes back to their country
their people already have immunity to
that to that to a variant of it so
they're much much less susceptible we
saw this with a Spanish Flu many people
wondered why it was that in China they
didn't actually get hit as hard as the
rest of the world when it came to
Spanish Flu it was like 1918 I think and
one of the arguments is that a similar
version was actually in China they all
got sick but not that bad got immunity
to it when it spread around in the
trenches and with the infections and the
grime it got substantially worse and
then when it came back to China they
were already mostly immune to it so now
that we're hearing they've they're
making what whether or not it's this
this coveted virus or whatever here's my
prediction my prediction is we see a
deadly strain of covid but it will
mostly just impact people countries that
haven't faced the severity of this which
I wonder which countries that is
countries with very low covet infection
and mortality rates I wonder what those
countries are do you know Luke usually
the places that weren't a part of the
the program that injected uh unknown
rushed experimental uh needle that's not
if you look at if you look at the
countries that have the most debts are
the places the ones that had the biggest
vaccination program let's just be real
right and those and that's why they were
putting the vaccination programs there
because they had more death there are
specific countries around the world
mostly in the third world that had very
low covet death and infection rates so
they didn't bring vaccines there but but
if these people don't have the immunity
either you know for vaccine or whatever
reason then you're going to see a
deadlier strain severely impact third
world countries in this in this case
well scientists see it just you know
there's a lot of scientific debate
that's actually being centered around
the specific topic especially when it
comes to you know countries like Haiti
comparatively to Israel Singapore what
happened there to other places but uh at
the end of the day natural immunity is
something that again also a topic that
has been sent entered a lot but natural
immunity has been key to a lot of
people's personal health and getting
through a lot of this nonsense and
bullcrap do you guys think Americans
would be willing to lock down again
because I questioned that in my head
like if they just did it all over again
I don't know no way where I live in New
York they would they're they're dying
well that's the thing blue States would
freaking out they were not locked down
but people are moving to Florida and
Texas yeah and so the blue States
probably would because you have a higher
density now of the people who want to
live under the boot right and then
South Dakota Florida Texas a bunch of
red States they wouldn't do it West
Virginia probably wouldn't do it yeah
yeah I don't know did New Hampshire Do
It
um not not it depends where because the
big cities especially with a lot of
people condensed they had their own
little versions of it but yeah the
government is very limited in New
Hampshire so it was up to a lot of
personal individuals personal businesses
to decide for themselves but as far as
comparing it to New York it was day and
night to what was going on there
um you know it depends what happens you
know there's also you know a scientific
thoughts and ideas that if a virus is
more deadly it's less contagious but
they're talking about how this bio uh
bio lab made Weapon It's sorry excuse me
this new strain of of coven made by
Boston University they're saying it was
a university I just want to be I think
Austin University are you sure uh yeah
uh you could double check just to make
sure we're right on this that ball
you're right you're right you're right
yeah but Boston University is also
reporting that this is five times more
contagious than the original covet virus
so it's more contagious and more deadly
that's that's something you know pretty
serious there because naturally viruses
uh just want to spread they want to live
they want to go from host to host to
host and not kill the host because when
you kill the host you stop the spread of
the virus so this one with the data that
they're reporting is very troubling
because High death count and high
transmability you know transmission
ability yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there